All right, let's dive into
something you might not even
realize you're hearing.
There's a sound this country
makes if you really know how to
listen for it.
Not the obvious stuff.
No, exactly.
Not the parades, not the
anthems, but something much
quieter, more intimate.
It's that you know that hushed
click of a basement fridge door
opening late at night.
Yeah, I know that sound.
You know the one, right?
And it's followed by those
muffled footsteps, someone
quietly bringing food
downstairs, maybe to a relative
who's supposed to stay for a
week, but, well, never quite
left.
Happens all the time.
It does.
And this, see, this is like the
audible pulse of America's
unacknowledged social safety
net.
The source material we looked at
actually calls it America's
Black market of Democratic
Socialism.
That's a striking phrase, isn't
it?
So our mission today is a deep
dive into this whole complex
societal workaround.
We're using this really powerful
metaphor from the sources a
house, a strict father, a soft
mother and this hidden basement.
To sort of unpack it all.
Exactly To illuminate this
secret safety net and the the
whole national debate that's
swirling around it.
OK, I'm with you.
So imagine America as this
House, right?
But it's like it was built
without a proper permit.
You can see the cracks and the
beams.
The walls are kind of propped up
by forces you don't normally
see.
Got a?
Bit shaky.
Bit shaky, yeah, And nailed to
the kitchen fridge by the strict
father, he's like the embodiment
of America's official story.
You know, rugged individualism,
free market.
Right.
The Constitution in boots, the
HOA president maybe?
Yeah, totally.
You find these rules like no
free ride, sink or swim.
Charity is good.
Coercion is theft.
Work or get out.
That's the official brand, we're
told.
The mythology.
OK.
But public face?
But then, then there's the soft
mother.
She's the work around.
She represents the the
administrative state, maybe
quietly stepping in, providing
for knees when those official
rules are just too harsh or they
just plain fail.
A quiet.
Fix Exactly.
And here's where it gets really
interesting for me in the source
material, the noise of this
so-called black market of
democratic socialism.
It's those muffled steps.
It's the mother slipping a fold
in 20.
It's that cousin who just stays.
It's the hum of that basement
fridge, a reality everyone kind
of knows exists deep down, but
nobody really wants to name.
Yeah, it's felt more than spoken
about.
So what exactly is in this
hidden basement?
According to the sources, What
does it actually hold?
Good question.
What lives down there?
Well, it's basically all the
things we publicly say we don't
need, but they're definitely
down there doing the work you've
got, like field church pantries,
right?
Quietly making sure whole blocks
don't go hungry.
Then there are these
neighborhood nonprofits.
And if you actually follow the
money, the sources say they're
often 80% federal money.
It's just channelled through,
well, it looks like shell games
sometimes. 80% Wow.
Yeah, even something like the
Peace Corps gets mentioned
describe as our hush hush export
version of the same idea.
You know, a bright eyed Kennedy
dream may be designed to make
poverty look less like
imperialism when we deal with it
overseas.
Never thought of it quite like
that.
And think about charities we
praise.
So many are actually built on
these hidden pipelines of grants
and subsidies.
We're talking about SNAP Peaks
EITC credit.
Earned Income Tax credit.
Exactly.
And even those pandemic
emergency dollars, remember how
much those prop things up.
Absolutely crucial stuff.
But this whole work around, it's
not on the blueprint as the
material puts it, it never got
the permit.
So why?
Why did it develop this way?
Well, the sources suggest it's
partly because there's this deep
historical distrust of big
government here, plus really
strong beliefs and individual
responsibility.
The strict father rules.
Exactly.
So it was politically easier,
maybe the path of least
resistance, to address real
needs this way quietly, rather
than try to vote for direct
public aid out in the open.
You preserve the ideal image
that way.
So it's not just accidental.
No, it's presented more like a
design feature or this other
quote, a moral contradiction
Americans keep on life support
because maybe they don't trust
each other enough to actually
vote for the real thing in
daylight.
A moral contradiction that
really hits home and it leads
right into this conflict, this
mold versus roses debate you see
in the sources.
Yeah, tell me about that split.
Well, the same hidden basement,
the same workaround.
It's viewed completely
differently depending on who's
looking for roughly, say, 30% of
people.
The sources link this view often
with progressives like Zoran
Mamdani.
He's a New York legislator.
For them, that basement is a
garden.
It's full of roses.
It's the soft blossom that keeps
the house humane, keeps
America's heart beating.
It's seen as vital mercy, you
know, making our hypocrisy a
little less, right.
But then you have the other
side, maybe 70%.
The rugged ones, the Iron Dad
ones, the people who
fundamentally see taxes theft.
For them, it's black mold, it's
moral decay, it's termites in
the joists that are sucking the
value and the the moral
character out of the house.
Wow, completely opposite views
of the exact same thing.
Exactly.
So what does it all mean?
It just highlights this deep
irony.
Both sides swear they care about
the house, about the people in
it.
But one sees the hidden help as
mercy, as a bloom, and the other
sees it as well as moral theft
or a dangerous rot.
And connecting that to the
bigger political picture, the
sources explained that for that,
70%, taxes really are seen as
theft.
Like, fundamentally they'd, and
this is a paraphrase, but they'd
rather stand shivering in an
empty lot than feel robbed to
build a greenhouse they never
agreed to.
That's a powerful image.
It is, and it's crucial, the
source of stress.
Neither side really wants people
to suffer.
But one side, like Mom, Donnie
argues, OK, let's bring the
fridge upstairs.
Let's plant the roses out front.
Let's make it official.
Tax, taxes, votes acknowledge
it, He basically says, look, we
are kind of a democratic
socialist country already in
some ways.
Just admit it and do it
properly.
Right.
But the other side, the 70%,
they want to tear it down
because they see it as a lie, as
this unpermitted addition that's
dragging down the property value
of their ideal America.
Which leads us straight to this
figure of Iron Dad and the whole
tear down idea, right?
How did past leaders handle this
this mold?
Well, the sources have some
interesting takes.
Reagan, they say, kind of
sniffed the mold and called it
character building.
Boosh Senior maybe shrugged.
Clinton put up some Third Way
wallpaper.
Covering it up a bit.
Yeah, and Obama even upgraded
the mini fridge and painted it.
Hope Glue, but none of them
really removed it or made it
official.
So it always stayed hidden.
Always stayed moms purse, never
the people's will.
That's a direct quote.
Then comes Donald Trump,
described as Iron dad 47.
He didn't invent the mold,
wasn't the 1st to see it, but he
came down with a flashlight, saw
it clearly.
A secret wing that never had a
permit full of people eating
from a fridge they never paid
for.
And his motivation?
According to this analysis, it
wasn't primarily about causing
pain.
But he hated the lie.
He hated the unpermitted nature
of it all.
So he called the inspector,
ready to strip it to the studs.
Uh huh.
Taking serious action.
Serious action.
And this is where it gets really
pointed.
You know that old saying from
Audra Lord, You cannot dismantle
the master's house with the
master's tools.
Yes, very famous quote.
Well, the source material flips
it.
It says actually you can tear
the whole thing down with them.
Whoa.
OK, unpack that.
Who is the master or the
landlord here and what are the
tools?
That's the crucial question the
material raises.
Because it's not just one
politician, right?
No, the twist is the landlord
isn't Trump or Reagan or Obama.
It's us the people.
Or more specifically, that 70%
who see taxes as theft and the
basement is mold.
So we are the landlord.
In this metaphor, yes.
And the real tool isn't even the
Supreme Court, though The court
acts like the inspector wearing
a tool belt, finding the
termites, the mildew, the
undocumented cousins.
OK, so what's the real tool?
The real tool is the lease, the
vote.
And it's short.
Four years.
Eight years.
Which means the next tenant, the
next administration, the next
voter mandate can come in and
just RIP out your carpet and
your moldy crawl space and your
beautiful hidden rugs.
Because it was never official.
Exactly.
The whole system is vulnerable
because it was never permitted.
It was never explicitly voted
for in the 1st place.
It's just a workaround with no
real defense when a determined
inspector shows up.
That makes the whole thing feel
incredibly precarious.
It does, and that leads to
another critical point, maybe an
ugly one that nobody likes to
say out loud.
Which is.
That not all of these workaround
roses are real.
They're not all genuine blossoms
of mercy.
What do you mean?
The source is used as powerful
parallel fighting a war with
private contractors like
Blackwater versus using budgeted
official soldiers.
OK, how does that connect?
Well, real soldiers are under
congressional oversight.
They're paid less, relatively
speaking.
They're part of the official
structure.
But private mercs?
They're super expensive. 1000
bucks a day sometimes.
Yeah, for work a corporal does
for way less per year, and they
often lack clear accountability
when things go wrong.
Right.
That's been a huge issue.
So how does this apply to the
social safety net?
It applies directly to what the
sources call our shadow social
democracy.
The material details how many
independent nonprofits are 80%
tax dollars funneled through
shell games.
Think about the effects.
What kind of effects?
Well, you see CEO's of these
nonprofits making more than
governors, maybe even generals.
Administrative costs running
hotter than the engine.
Big parties, endless
consultancies.
Wow, sounds like grift.
It's framed as basically a
mercenary system for social
support, which raises a really
important question.
Is the cost of hiding our safety
net that it becomes incredibly
inefficient and opaque?
Because you need middle men.
Exactly.
When you hide it, you risk
filling it with middle men who
profit from Allied that it's
private.
They're selling plastic roses
dusted with rose water.
Plastic roses?
That's bleak.
It is it's unpermitted mercy and
it creates this whole black
market economy of moral middle
men.
And they have an incentive to
keep the mold hidden, maybe
manage it, but never really get
rid of it.
Because they profit from the
secrecy.
Precisely.
And that secrecy, that opacity,
it can also just breed cynicism
among the public, right, which
makes it even harder to ever
build support for a system
that's truly transparent and,
you know, codified.
Which brings us right back to
the present dilemma, the choice
facing the landlord.
Yeah, the decision point.
You have Zoran Mamdani's vision.
OK, Bring the fridge upstairs.
Put the kids in the living room
where they belong.
Pass the HOA vote.
Build a real greenhouse.
Pay for it with taxes.
Be honest about it.
The open daylight approach.
Contrasted sharply with Iron
Dad's stance, which is not on my
lease, not while I hold the
crowbar back to the studs.
No compromise there.
Be grateful it's not a full tear
down yet.
Next time maybe it will be.
And meanwhile, the mother, the
administrative state, is
pictured rummaging through this
emptying purse, just wondering
if the kids will ever get their
own house.
Or if the mold just takes over
completely.
Yeah.
Or if they just keep living in
her basement till the mold wins.
So looking at the bigger
picture, the ultimate question
really boils down to do you want
the roses, the real men's
growing out in the daylight, or
are you OK with this hidden,
very vulnerable workaround?
That seems to be the core
choice.
And if you do want the real
roses, the sources are pretty
clear.
You're going to have to stand
out front and admit they cost
money.
They cost taxes, votes, line
items.
You have to own it.
You have to basically say out
loud that you'd rather keep your
neighbors fed than cling to some
illusion of rugged cowboy
freedom that maybe never really
existed for everyone anyway.
But there is that counter
argument too.
Right there is you have to
acknowledge the other view.
Maybe the mold was always fatal.
Maybe a tear down is necessary
to build something honest,
something truly based on the
stated principles.
Starting over from scratch?
Right.
But, the sources warn, if that's
the path you choose, don't fool
yourself.
The new house won't come with
floaties.
There won't be a hidden safety
net anymore.
Sink or swim for real this time.
Pretty much.
And if you do decide you want
some kind of safety net in that
new house, well, you'd better
plant them in the front yard,
vote for them, tax yourself for
the fence, and stand guard when
the next dad calls the bulldozer
'cause it will need defending.
Wow.
OK, so this deep dive really
has, I think, pulled back the
curtain on this secret safety
net we often pretend isn't
there, this whole black market
of democratic socialism
operating like right under our
feet.
Yeah, it's a powerful lens and.
We've navigated that core
dilemma, the contrast between
the mercy, however hidden from
the mother's purse, and the very
real potential for a tear down
from Iron Dad and that 70% who
just see corrosive mold.
Yeah.
So ultimately, maybe the
question for you, the listener,
to really ponder is this.
If a house is what you say it
is, you know, on paper, in the
building code, in your
neighbor's heart.
And if this mold we've been
talking about is actually the
price you pay for lying to
yourself about needing help.
Then what do you really lose
when you pretend you never
needed that help in the 1st
place?
Just remember, in this story,
the landlord is US.
The vote is the lease.
And the lease is short.
Very short.
The inspector is already on the
porch, the bulldozer is warming
up, and if you don't speak now,
well, the next cold night is
eventually going to come for
you, too.
A.
Sobering thought to end on.
Sleep tight and maybe keep your
ears on the floorboards.